so I'm really excited to introduce you
to all the not all but many were
incredible women that I get to work with
every day and these are the partners of
Y Combinator and so yeah so I would love
for we're going to be answering some of
the questions that you sent us and so
I'd love for each of you to introduce
yourselves and then we'll just jump in
okay shall I stop okay hi again everyone
I'm Kirsty Nasu I'm the CFO here at Y
Combinator and I've been involved with
YC now since 2010 so seen it go through
a lot of changes i'm carolyn levy i'm
partner and general counsel at like Omni
I've been here for about five years
hi everyone I'm a new Harry Haran I'm a
partner at Y Combinator's continuity
fund
I joined YC last year the continuity
fund is fairly new we invest primarily
in growth stage companies and help with
company building at scale hi my name is
adore Chun I have a partner at YC one of
the group partners meaning I work
directly with the startups I've been
here for about a year now a little over
a year and I went through YC myself in
2010 I guess one Kirsty started yeah
I'm Jessica living cinema co-founder YC
and I'm Kat and I've been at YC for
about four years now
and started out as the first director of
outreach so working with a lot of
potential applicants like you guys all
right let's just dive into the questions
and so how much industry experience you
typically recommend founders have zero
zero yeah well no actually I think for
for biotech it's pretty important that
the founder have industry experience but
not not true further oh also it's how do
you interpret that question because in
my talk earlier I said that ideas grow
organically out of founders lives and
usually they're working in some given
industry and they're an expert in it and
they say gosh this aspect is totally
broken I know how to fix it and so we
love funding people with
main expertise I guess actually these
people have been in the industry for
just just a little bit not too not too
long so that they are so entrenched in
it that they don't know how to fix it or
know how to build to fix it but yes just
long enough to kind of experience the
problem they like this is insane I have
to fix it
right yeah and so yeah I think it oh I
see I've seen folks that have had zero
industry experience and something that
they're launching and then some peak
folks that have had years at many years
so I guess it really just depends but
there's no I guess there's no simple
answer to that no side will answer I
don't think drew Houston had a whole lot
of experience in storage when he got
frustrated because he'd left his talk
you know back and he was on the the bus
to New York and so here's a stats
question what percentage of applications
have a female co-founder or how many
what percentage of you know I guess the
overall population are women so I'll
take this one
but I'd say I obsess enough I obsess
over the stats and so right now we're
seeing about 13% of the founders that
apply to YC are women and so I just want
to let that sink in because I want that
to be closer to 50% of the population of
people applying and thank you and then
for about 20 to 23 percent of the
companies have a female founder and
there are very very few companies that
apply that are you know female only
teams and so I would love to see more of
that as well um what is a myth about
starting startups or about YC that you
wish you could dispel I cannot answer
that question right in a day on that one
I'll probably do stuck without a view
your concern I think especially because
I joined YC only a year ago and I
remember after going through all the
interview process and was super excited
about having gotten the offer when I was
talking to other people and what are
some of the myths that I think now that
I've spent the year I can say so one is
I think it's a myth that we don't invest
in non
technical founders we do I think the
other myth is that we don't invest in
solo founders I think we encourage
having co-founders for various reasons
but there is no strict rule that says
it's an absolute no and the third thing
which actually really surprised me
because I had never thought that in my
head is that why she has no women yeah
so and I when I went through the due
process actually met her or doesn't have
a women child pounder yes so I think
that that's you know that I never had
that doubt especially because I had met
all of them through the interview
experience and now that worked at YC for
almost a year I can certainly say with
conviction that you know women play a
central role in every decision in YC I
think I get frustrated because I feel
like women often get written out of a
lot of stories right I mean this is this
is a thing that we see in time and time
again and I was just telling someone
this morning about this back when I
started YC all these reporters were
right about YC and they would refer to
dusk as like pilgrims wife right only
this Friday
Paul Graham's life in YC you know that
Jessica's the founder of YC right and
it's it's such [ __ ] and it was like
that she and she like it has like half
of the operating part of YC and so it
would just frustrate us internally and
then yesterday's story came out that
referenced Jessica's co-founder there
was no mention of light for anything and
I was like progress so like I was in
post the real bet you were given like
you're due there was some article that
came out that said Paul Graham Jessica
Livingston's husband can I say something
homie thing because there there are too
many for me to even address and some I
get very emotional about but when I hear
things like people come up and say oh
but you don't fund solo founders like it
breaks my heart what I'd love for just
people who would like to give us a
chance is to say okay I've read a lot of
these articles I think this is the case
let me make sure let me just ask if
that's true with someone who went
through YC and see what their experience
is like so that that's my only request
if you do come across a myth that you
think is true remember there's always
several sides to a story and not to
believe everything you read on Twitter
or in the press you know actually I just
want to say one thing
even after we fund solo female founders
they still don't believe it I was having
dinner with one of our female founders
from last winter and she said to me why
did you guys fund me and I'm like what a
weird question Wendy why did we find
she's like on female I don't have a
co-founder I was like seriously it was
like four weeks into the program and she
was still doubting it was depressing
a little bit but there's a question that
this actually nicely dovetails into is
that you know YC has funded
non-technical founders and sometimes
even non-technical solo founders what
was it about those founders when they
applied and interviewed at YC that
impressed you and you know I guess
convinced everyone for me its they have
a clear vision of what they want to
build and they have a clear roadmap of
how to get there step-by-step and they
understand that today I need to I maybe
I lack a technical co-founder
but I know how to hack my way into those
next steps
another good indication is if you've
been a product manager or head of P cute
like a p.m. somewhere and you've worked
with a lot of Engineers and you've
directed an orchestrated
product building before I think that's a
really good historical reference to that
you can build product without meeting a
technical co-founder I think it depends
on the kind of products as well not not
all products that get built need to have
super technical founders and as long as
you you have let you say the language to
be able to understand what takes a long
time what doesn't to be able to talk to
engineers to be able to set out the
product and their Maps that's what's
needed and you don't
not all founders have to be deeply
deeply technical and I lastly I'll just
wrap this up there is no one type of
founder we fund that we never say never
about anything there are just so many
different things we do so I wouldn't
want anyone to think why she never funds
blank because that's not true
hey does YC fund and work with later
stage companies I will kick that over to
you yeah sure so yes yes we do
so the YC continuity fund that was
launched two years ago our primary goal
is to really help support the companies
in the growth state so we do invest in
companies in the later stage what we're
really at that stage what we're really
looking for is has the company sort of
figured out its product market fit and
you know they're really raising money
for scale and many of the activities
that we help in that stage is really
with company building right because the
early stage program does a fantastic job
of really helping you figure out how to
get to product market fit and you know
really you're just starting in the
initial phase of the company which is
you know 1 to 10 employees or 20 but
when you get to 30 people and you're
scaling now to 100 or 200 or even 500
people the problems are different your
job is a CEO changes so we helped along
with a lot of elements in that phase I
think it's also it coming back to the
idea of myths that people make up their
own myths about Y Combinator that bear
no resemblance to anything and so they
convinced themselves that I'm too early
for Y Combinator I'm too late for Y
Combinator and again there's there's no
there's no too early and there's no too
late we fund companies all all stages
and so people put them people make the
our decisions for us by not supplying
lets us make that decision okay next
question is what advice do you have for
a mom who wants to start a company the
modern parent I got another baby because
that's what started there like that's my
that's what I always think when I'm
talking to the founders I think God
sounds like having another kid because
they take that much work so that's
that's the way I would think about it
like it's like having more kids I
actually asked Diane Greene this at our
first female founders conference when
she came to spoke I took was behind it
backstage with her and I said how do you
do this because I at this point had to
my two children one was just a baby
and I was struggling a little bit it's a
lot
a lot of work to juggle everything and I
said how did you run VMware and you know
have kids while you were doing all that
and she gave me some good advice which
was she really made an effort to
outsource a lot of things that didn't
have to do with specifically her
children so she had a gardener she had
someone who came in to clean her house
and did all these things because she did
couldn't do everything so outsource the
stuff that can be done by someone else
you know I used insta part all the time
and I got anything that could be
delivered I had delivered save me a
drive to the grocery store drive
wherever and so I always I always
appreciated that advice because it seems
reasonable but I hadn't really
implemented it yeah I would say you know
if you're really passionate about
something do it it doesn't matter
the timing is never right there is no
perfect time to start something you know
three years ago I met Nicole sherry as
Farb
she started a company and I actually met
her because she was pitching her startup
to us at the time and I had just
delivered a baby at that time and I
thought my life was crazy and so I kept
I finished the pitch meeting and I told
her Nicole my kid is really sick is it
okay if I get back to you in two days
and she understood and she never
mentioned anything I later got to know
that she had just delivered twins two
days up for my kid and I was like wow
what was I thinking so I just think that
you know there are a lot of women who I
have seen quite a few I mean it's not in
mass numbers but who at least in recent
years have seen it doesn't does no right
time and you cannot work wait for the
perfect time so if you are really
committed and you know that a steep
thing you want to work go do it
there's actually a really good example
backstage the to the proving founders so
we just accept on this batch and when
they interviewed us I had no clue but
they were both pregnant
and so their problem backstage hustling
and like talking to people and trying to
get users for their products what
they're like pregnant but they're doing
it so if you're passionate about you can
tell if are apart are the due dates
I think one month I serve that will
probably be hectic
one they said they're going to share
babysitters they're going to show you
everything so else's and so next
question is if you're working on the
side project at what point would you
feel comfortable going full-time on it
when should you bail out of her job or
think about taking time off school I
think I think there's two pieces to that
one is you feel like it's you're ready
to go all in obviously and it's like
getting some directions that's a good
sign too is I mean financial concerns so
if you're if you have low personal burn
I mean this is why really young people
start startups probably more than maybe
older folks but if you're in a
financially good place to take off for a
year that's probably a good place to
start and I'd say try to focus full time
as soon as you can if it's okay with you
financially try to do it sooner than
later I always say like you got to burn
the boat before you can really make the
kind of progress you can but then again
I'm talking out of both sides of my
mouth because a lot of times I say oh
don't put your job if you're thinking of
starting a startup work on something on
the side and see how it goes but the
point is once it starts getting a little
traction the sooner you can focus
full-time the better obviously it is for
that company and I really like time what
Morgan it said she was well she was
working at Intuit she'd started you know
the the first version of blabbity and
then there was like that moment where
you know she'd started to build you know
an audience but also was so passionate
it just like pulled her out and I
thought that was pretty cool it's also
one of the reasons why YC exists because
you can if you're ready kind of fly and
get in you can quit your job the forcing
function and so here's a question about
investors so and this person says I'm
told much of the small talk that
investors do it's really a disguised way
of identifying distractions so
specifically when investors ask about
your kids your social life or is that
just a way that you know they're trying
to identify red flags so and what's the
best way to handle those questions or
handle this like casual seeming chitchat
you have a good introvert okay I can I
can dig it I mean it's not just I think
that the question is
actually broader than investor I
actually started my career as an
engineer and when did the East Coast and
then came back to Silicon Valley so I've
gotten this question many times
meaning when I was married they wanted
to know if I was on mommy track
I had a baby ten years later and you
know if when I was pregnant it was like
am I going to quit and now that I have a
child sometimes you know there are other
questions aren't how much time I can
give but to be like honest like if you
pick the right work setting you don't
run into that right so but how do you
handle these questions one if these
questions are with an intention of their
trying to find distractions it's a red
flag like you may not want to work with
that person because they truly don't
understand where you come from and how
committed you are to doing what you're
doing so in those cases like if you know
someone asked me about staffing on a
project and whether I was going to be
pregnant I would just and if I felt that
it was an uncomfortable question because
they're trying to figure it out I just
asked you know openly like why is it a
concern and you know and often when you
put people on the spot they sometimes
give it to you asses and you know one of
these managers had told me well I'm
little concerned because this project is
really intense so I just want to be sure
and I I just respond I knew the
situation so I just said look I won't be
signing up for this if I didn't know I
could do it and that was enough to you
know shut that you know shut the problem
aside and move on so I think it depends
on the situation some of them I do think
maybe they're just asking just to get to
know you and that sort of their way to
break the ice you have to tease apart
what why the question came but if you
sense that they're doing this because
they want to figure out if there's a
distraction just pop them openly and
that has always worked for me
and you know more often after a few
years there was a joke within our front
nobody would ever ask me that question
it has another way you know ever do that
there's a slip side to this which is
that I think we have heard from some
founders that married co-founders that
they didn't disclose to investors that
they were married and then it kind of
went on for too long and then they
didn't actually know when to disclose it
without it being super awkward so that's
something to navigate as well I don't
know what the exact right answer is
there but
that can come up so it's probably best
to sort of be upfront about some of the
stuff kind of depends but you don't want
to hide the ball on this stuff because
it can get awkward later yeah I mean I
think what Laura was saying in her talk
about transparency and being really
transparent with investors is important
because that's you know she was saying
that she hopes like that you know she
expects the same from Ben like they'll
be honest with her and so I think
probably it's best to bring up sooner
than later and if they don't you know
invest in married couples and like
forget them yes mate um but most of the
investors I've talked to are not
concerned by that they just want to know
right I guess so and so we only have a
couple minutes left so and one question
is who are your mentors and what is
there anything I guess really put that
they've taught you that stuck with you
also first I I think that I don't have a
specific mentor that I can point to and
I it kind of makes me laugh this
question because when I was at the law
firm where I worked before Y Combinator
I was in a women's group and we
endlessly debated the whole topic of
mentorship because there's this whole
debate like should it be organic or
should you connect people we just all we
did was talk about it but I didn't
actually have a specific mentor but I
realized like I learned a lot of stuff
from every single one of my colleagues I
continue to learn from my colleagues at
YC and one of my biggest takeaways that
I've learned from my colleagues is
customer service and that applies in the
legal world as well as everywhere else
always give good customer service always
put your client customer whatever it is
first yeah it's kind of hard I guess and
we're doing what we're doing which is
such an unusual thing the a lot of you
know you kind of pick pieces of
information up from lots of different
people and it's all pieces of a jigsaw
that you piece together but definitely
the people that we work with I'm the
same way I pick up different things from
different people and I just have this
patchwork quilt of like fabulous lessons
that I've learned from people and I'm
when when the dinners are going on at YC
and there's a founder telling their
story
I am listening just as intent
as all the founders in the group I mean
I learned so much from the people that
come through the doors of YC and my
colleagues when I was starting my
startup there when I first came in
Silicon Valley there were some people
that were influential helped me along
the way
so my former boss that first startup Max
Levchin helped me a lot and he he in
fact funded part of my startup and Paul
Graham of course but I would say in
terms of running my startup and like
someone to talk to on a weekly or even
monthly basis I didn't have that person
and I wish I did and I wish I had seeks
that person out I guess and I think it's
helpful to have someone who's not your
investor you're not related to who's not
your friend per se like a personal
friend who you can talk to about these
things and bounce ideas off of if you
have any tips for so looking for those
people are me most people so I didn't
find what's debate how do you behind the
person it's tough cause you do want it
to be organic right to some extent um
but I think for me the the some of the
most important like recurring people in
my life has been advocates so I was like
not just mentors but people have always
advocate for me I think I used to work
with Alexis Ohanian the founder of
Reddit he's always been like a
cheerleader like a supporter and you
know I but I think I would say the same
thing I pick up a lot from everyone I
work with especially you guys and then
also the founders that come in I'm
constantly learning and then I also as
their companies grow I also learn as as
you know they kind of share their
experience with me so I just we are out
of time and so I hope you've learned as
much as we've learned today I'm
listening to boundaries here and
Jennifer coming
[Music]
[Applause]
you